[Music]
any more coffee like what's your
favorite xbox one exlusive 2019
state of decay to son yeah what's your
second favorite force of horizon for son
was your third favorite I don't have one
do you care that there's not that many
no there wasn't that many last year
either but this year I feel like for all
the promise to see if he showed didn't
really hit me hard at all
and that was April no no that [ __ ] bro
listen yeah hang out for a while now and
I feel like they were trying to make
this you know like lifestyle game that
people would keep returning to and I
don't even feel like many people are
talking about it anymore
because there's not much there XO 18 so
exile yeah in Mexico City in Mexico City
then on so there's gonna be like a
arena-style thing that they're bringing
up for next year's is they're still
supporting it so clear there must be
people still playing it but I don't
think it made the splash thank you I was
waiting for that thank you yeah people
loved like the little bits and pieces of
that game it's just that that isn't
enough to sustain it and like they had
these big you know all here's a crack in
under water leave it meanwhile someone
got the camera underwater and it's just
disembodied arms at the surface like
coming up up and you can't even kill it
magic your video game yeah but there was
all this promise of like being you do
that again I don't what do they do
funny no we're doing that now there's
all this sort of like promise from
Microsoft of what the game could deliver
and I just don't think that it really
capitalized well I just didn't perform
yeah all the showmanship being above the
surface with nothing underneath is a
pretty good metaphor for that game damn
I don't I don't think there's anything
left to say then no but then you also
mentioned in Forza horizon for that
released more recently you said you
didn't play it even though it's set in
your neck of the woods
no no just cuz this courts have been so
busy I haven't really
to it and also the fact that I moved
from England and I felt like I would be
upset if I play because I'd be missing
home too much
yeah but for horizon that series is
always every single iteration it's been
about it so I'm genuine looking forward
to playing it maybe over Christmas do
you play mm-hmm I like it a lot and I'm
not traditionally a racing game person
especially not for two but obviously
that one is a little more accessible
because of its open world and just the
fact that you can like roam around doing
random challenge that was another I
think the beautiful thing about the
forts a game especially for its the
horizon for is that even if you're not a
car person there's still a lot to
appreciate
it kind of makes you want to be a car
person it's kind of like interestingly
enough how I always felt about top gear
like even if you don't like cars it
still kind of makes you interested in
cars and that this weekend it's still
great but then this definitely has a
similar feeling like I'm excited to get
behind the wheel of some of these cars
and like not even necessarily race I
just like to kind of cruise around see
what other people are doing which is
normally crashing into me but yeah that
game is a lot of fun we're talking about
Xbox exclusives state of decay to came
out and people are excited for it
because of how much of a cult hit the
first one was from undead labs like
really great zombie immersive sim I
guess you could call it and I've been
playing state of decay to again recently
they have vastly improved it but when
the game released it was very very
broken in a lot of places there are a
lot of like quality of life things that
need to be changed which they have but
it didn't really add much to the stable
of Xbox games but we're just how about
playground games and undead labs those
are two of these studios that Microsoft
acquired this year acquired total Hey
right something like it 583 so an EXO 80
name is playground on dead labs and then
the compulsion games who made we have a
few there were several other ninja
theory which is huge as bad that was
really good because it's like it's
there's also like a wide range of games
then there's also obsidian they have
which again we're talking about it
during our PC chat obsidian is very much
like an old-school RPG developer they
made a lot of those their pillows are
pillars of eternity to this year which
now we know yeah and now we know that's
the last game they made it as an
independent studio but now it I think
made Microsoft making really good moves
because I wouldn't peg obsidian to go to
Microsoft despite the fact that the
original Xbox did have a lot of console
RPGs there's a key difference though
down like you can hook up a keyboard and
mouse to your Xbox port right it's
basically and they're really going in on
that and I think that works really well
because it's already like it's so
seamless between Windows 10 and Xbox
like state of decay to I'm playing it
here and then the cloud saves bring it
to my xbox at home it's still just first
part well I mean I guess certificate 2
wasn't active
first party at that point but it is now
it is now whatever but yeah like it so
you can tell like that's really only
available for certain game yeah love
that to be available for the entire Xbox
like I couldn't that's a reality that's
like too good to be true yeah but it's
cool to see if they're making strides to
begin with the Microsoft not only are
they acquiring these great third-party
studios they are making a new first
party studio so they've got the
initiative and they're pulling in all
this amazing triple-a talent from
basically their cherry picking who they
want to make a game and I'm really
excited to see what that group of people
are going to come out with so in top of
that they have you know they announced a
new Halo we've got a ton of stuff about
gears coming it's again putting all
their pieces on the board and moving
everything forward
no we the one thing I'm concerned about
all these other studios is I really hope
like I feel like Microsoft in three six
you'd be like great we have this new
studio how can you make us a Halo game
or how can you make us accuse of working
I really hope they don't do that and
like like hearing about fable was
exciting because we haven't seen that
franchise in a long time
and I you know like say what you will
about fable like they were still
entertaining games I thought but I
really hope we see some really
interesting new IPs because that is
something that I feel like Xbox has
really been missing for a while I mean
we had to see a Thieves which was kind
of fine but like I really want to see
something interesting that's not a
variation on Halo I feel like last year
we're also saying Xbox is prime for a
better year next year I'm just I'm
hoping they don't repeat that again
because I don't think it was like I
don't necessarily know that it was a bad
year in terms of news they had a lot of
good announcements to fit their PR this
year the things they've done for the
community the families have been huge
like I'd say bigger than one or two
exclusives here they're backwards
compatibility has been like it awesome
move control yeah controller was really
good the fact that the package itself
you could open it if you didn't even
liked it and and that controller can be
used under the devices just yesterday
someone was like here's how to use it on
swish yeah like that's pretty cool but
the games past too like personally I
reused it just because typically we get
complimentary codes and stuff like that
but that seems like insane value for
those yeah they're like what's 10 bucks
a month then you can play a launch on it
right yeah games on like see if these
did fortune did what is it mutant to
your zero it's gonna launch on that does
another thing from EXO 18 the past oh oh
sorry the past couple years for expert
for me have felt like the last two
seasons of Game of Thrones where they've
been good but nothing huge and huge in
the Xbox way talks would be like the
first part exclusives right but the past
two years have been great past your
seasons a game of has been great and
they've been kind of moving towards
big thing that you know they're gonna
have an incredible year and I really
hope that next year is that incredible
year because they've been making all of
these strides and moving towards making
really smart business decisions
acquisitions things of the playerbase
and I just hope that if and when next
next-gen comes they're gonna be ready
for it
well they're already talking about last
e3 day we're saying yes we're working on
the next thing with it xbox scarlet or
something major yeah you know the ex is
still really powerful and really cool
and yeah a game like Red Dead comes
along
yeah PlayStation has exclusive content
but everyone agrees incredible yeah the
first time people are like you if you
have the option you need to play this
game on the X and like for all the
touting they've done for the most
powerful console in the world right now
finally like just something to like say
oh look that's an example of it yeah I
know like you when you replay the game
you made sure to do it on I think I
remember last year saying like I have
this great Xbox one X I haven't really I
haven't really seen how powerful it is I
feel like because it's most the stuff
that's been releasing on apart from
fourth set like it hasn't been you know
blowing my mind but playing Red Dead on
that it's it's incredible it looks I
don't wanna say way better because it
looks great anywhere you play it but it
looks fantastic I finally feel like wow
I am playing the best possible version
of a game on this Xbox one X yeah I feel
like in general on all it wasn't the
biggest year for their catalogue but
when you start to like dig into and look
at all the different things I found that
the adaptive controller like business
moves on their acquisition and like PR
in general I think it's actually a
really good year and I kind of
cautiously optimistic that all these
moves are setting up fantastic 2019 so
that's the one thing I'm not sure if I
feel that 2019 is gonna be their year I
think with all of these studio
acquisitions still kind of fresh I think
it's gonna be 2020 here I think they're
really gonna hit hard on whatever this
next gen Xbox scarlet or whatever it is
I think that's gonna be the really
impressive year so maybe end of next
year if I mean this is all just
conjecture I have no idea but maybe end
of next year it's just really promising
to like four years now barbering at
Microsoft for not having many first
party exclusives and like every year
you're looking at 343 or coalition if
they don't have some come out there
interesting oh they'll have something
next year Microsoft heard that or they
just already had plans and they went out
and got talented third-party developers
and said come and make stuff for us
exclusively and that's a really good
move on there and I think in it
again it's like has me optimistic for
their future and looking back on 2018 is
a really good year for Microsoft so
anyway those were our broad strokes
about Microsoft in 2018 if you want to
go more in depth and get into the
specifics we have a full report card
from our editorial team over on
gamespot.com we will also be covering
Sony PC and Nintendo throughout the
coming weeks for our end of the year
awards stay FINA GameSpot
[Music]